nous venons d'entendre la déclaration du
premier ministre concernant la reprise
dans les établissements scolaires avec
une reprise différencier entre le
premier degré et le second degré avec
aussi un certain nombre d incertitudes
quant à la reprise éventuelle des lycées
puisqu'il la positionne et
éventuellement pour le mois de juin
la chose qui est évident pour nous c'est
que c'est un gouvernement extrêmement
dogmatique pour lequel l'économie un
prime avant tout bien sûr il n'est pas
question de dire que l'économie ne n'est
pas importante
c'est très important dans la mesure où
on sait qu'il y aura beaucoup de
précarité à la suite de ses difficultés
de confinement cependant comme par
hasard on veut reprendre le premier
degré les écoles maternelles et les
écoles primaires ainsi que les sixièmes
et les cinquièmes dans un premier temps
puisque tout simplement ce sont les
enfants qui sont les plus en difficulté
pour ceux occupés de même tout seul pour
l'instant en tout cas nous n'avons pas
entendu grand chose non plus concernant
la sécurité qui sera obligatoire au sein
de ces établissements scolaires de tout
ce qui lui mettront à disposition en a
entendu parler de masques quand même
cependant nous attendons de savoir
précisément si nous aurons des masques
du chat libre la alcoolique et bien
évidemment de l'eau dans les
établissements scolaires de martinique